that's fine hey I'm Kristin and I work
at github but this talk isn't like about
me as an engineer at get up it's more of
a user so before I started working
github I would have all these kinda like
ideas about like I wish github could do
this one thing and I would write these
chrome extensions to kind of help my
workflow to do these things there but
there's like some things that but
there's some stuff that I couldn't do as
Chrome extensions and so for those
things I recently discovered this
library that is not the right clicker
it's called pro bot and it's a library
for github to write these github
applications and pro bot does this by
leveraging web hooks and the k-dub api
to give you kind of the power to extend
github in a in a pretty simple way and
most instances of pro bots are
responding to events so something
happens on github Probot gets a ping
through a web hook and it might like
analyze like what should I do in this
situation and it will maybe fire off
some events of its own and we can
actually take I have a little trivial
example and let's say if we want to
respond to every issue that's opened in
a repository and like let's just like
say hello just give them a little
welcoming message all right we're gonna
build it right now so we have this
module and it just takes in robot as
argument or a parameter and so we can
attach event listeners on the robot and
there's a list on the github
documentation page for the events you
can listen for and here we're just like
listening for if there's any issue
that's opened we get this context with
it and so with this context we can
create a comment this is kind of
confusing I didn't really understand
this at first but this is essentially
just gives you like an object back that
operates in the context of the
issue and we just give it the body
thanks for the issue and then just using
get up get up API if you ever used it
it's pretty it's fairly simple we just
say create this comment and that's it
it's pretty easy like we can run this
and every time somebody opens up an
issue on a repository where this Probot
isn't against its installed it will
respond
thanks for the issue I thought this was
pretty cool when I saw it first because
you can do these crazy things there's a
bunch of Pro BOTS out there you might
have seen them if you go into these
popular get up repositories sometimes
they'll like close down the issues when
nobody is commenting on it for some days
and I have a problem that I really
wanted to solve with Probot and it is
related to es lint I don't know if
everybody here uses lint but I almost
always use it in my projects and I have
it running so like it will run in a
built and if if someone broken easily
through it will give you like a red
status on the floor request there's just
one problem with this people can just
like disable the rules right there in
the code and so this is a project that I
have where somebody just disabled all
the rules and just did whatever they
want it which is fine like I understand
that sometimes people just like need to
get stuff done and so they like they're
like I don't know how to do this I just
I know how to use jQuery show I don't
know how to like show and hide things so
I'm like empathetic to it but I I maybe
would want it to like focus that you
shouldn't do this or like ping me and
tell and I can explain them how they can
do it correctly so like this previous
one it just goes through like
everything's green people are like great
Mercer pull requests I like I said I
would like for these to be flagged so I
wrote this Probot that I gave it a
little logo
here's a logo with eyes emoji and so it
just watches pull requests and when a
poor cousin comes in it checks the diff
and if somebody added I isn't disabled
it will just comment right on there just
please please don't there's a really
great thing you can if you install Pro
BOTS into your repositories you can give
him convicts
so my Probot you can change this message
and like if you wanna if you wanna give
him like a little image you can do that
you can like at the team that should
review this be like at the j/s team to
be like you can you know you don't have
to use jQuery show you can do this thing
and yeah if they're like legitimate is
lint disables this talk went by really
fast you can find Probot on github robot
dog awl and my Probot is on my github
which is up there thank you
[Applause]